all of these parents for the last year
or two that have been complaining about
these porn style books that are
available to students why hasn't anyone
with their right mind saying that this
should not be available to students this
should not be available to
five-year-olds and if you're going to
make it available to your your students
it should be at an appropriate age but
but here's the part though I'm open to
being sold if you can logically sell it
to me how are they selling that that's
normal that you should be okay with that
how are you selling it to parents yeah
so there's these things I call it gay
privilege when you paint something as
inclusivity you plant you paint it as
Pride you painted as love as my
community you automatically get this
precedent that if you do not go along
with this then you're homophobic or
you're transphobic and no one wants to
fall under that category based on how
our society perceives these people
foreign
[Music]